- [Announcer] This UCSD-TV program is
presented by University of California
television. Like what you learn? Visit
our website or follow us on Facebook and
Twitter to keep up with the
latest programs.
♪ [music] ♪
- [Narrator] We are the paradoxical ape:
bipedal, naked, large-brained. Long the
master of fire, tools and language, but
still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable yet filled
with optimism. We grow up slowly. We
hand down knowledge, we empathize and
deceive. We shape the future from our
shared understanding of the past. CARTA
brings together experts from diverse
disciplines to exchange insights on who we
are and how we got here, an exploration
made possible by the generosity of
humans like you.
♪ [music] ♪
- [Margaret] Welcome. We begin another
extremely interesting session with some
very promising speakers in front of me.
I'm Margaret Schoeninger, I'm co-director,
one of the co-directors, of CARTA and I
just, again, want to say welcome. For
CARTA, as the video was portraying, we're
very interested in the oldest questions of
humans. So what we're looking at is who
are we? What are we doing here? We all are
interested in in this. Where do we come
from? How did we get here? Where are we
going? But there're only really two
questions of that list that we can begin
to really address scientifically, really
collect data on them. So that's why CARTA
was formed. CARTA is anthropogeny and it
is trying to explain the origin of humans.
It's from an old dictionary saying, an
Oxford dictionary in 2006 actually put it
together came from 1839 and so we do
anything we can to try to understand the
origin of humans. We are a rather large
group at this point, we started very small
but we're a pretty large group now, with
three co-directors, one of whom is in
front of me, Professor Ajit Varki, Rusty
Gage was unable to join us. I see the
Associate Director here, Pascal Gagneux,
who actually was the voiceover in the
previous video. We have a management
services officer you're gonna see walking
around the room a lot, Linda Nelson.
Community relations director, I saw
walking all around, Ingrid, and she's
still working, Ingrid Benirschke-Perkins.
We have a computer programmer analyst
who's taking care of all the
live streaming. That
is Kate Kaya, program director Jesse
Robie and administrative assistant Stefi
Petit. I think you would get this from the
video but just in case you didn't we are
pulling together experts from multiple
fields all over. We add as we find an
interesting target, so we have people from
physical and chemical sciences, biomedical
sciences, social sciences all across
campus. We have a mission statement that
we will use all rational and ethical
approaches to seek verifiable facts from
all relevant disciplines to explore and
explain the origins of the human
phenomenon. We try to minimize complex
organizational structure and hierarchies
but, as I was talking to someone at lunch,
as we've gotten larger and larger that is
becoming more and more difficult. We try
to avoid unnecessary paperwork and
bureaucracy but it's very difficult to do
with a large organization as we are now.
In the process, we really are trying to
raise awareness and understanding of this
study of human origins within the academic
and also the public at large, which is why
we do these large public presentations. In
order to do that, we have one
exceptionally wonderful sponsor, it is the
G. Harold and Layla Mathers charitable
foundation of New York with Jim Handelman,
who is the executive director, who often
comes but is not here today. This is going
to be video recorded with closed
captioning due to the generosity of Rita
Atkinson, Liz Lancaster, Eli Shefter and
also Sue Rosner. And I want to thank
especially Annette Merle-Smith because
there are some young people here and they
are here because of her generosity in
providing support for some of our fellows
within our anthropogeny specialization
track. So thank you Annette. We have...
Yes, thank you Annette.
We have a number of individual sponsors
and we are grateful to each one of them. I
also want to thank UCSD-TV for the video
recording and some of the closed
captioning and Salk Media Services. We
wouldn't be here if it weren't for the
Salk Media people. So in order to begin I
am going to turn this over to our
co-chair, Steve Churchill, from Duke
University and let him begin. Thank you.
♪ [music] ♪